But the idea that I want
a test to kind of get through.
And this was actually an idea proposed
by Levin et al in their paper.
Which is also referenced at
the end of this lecture and
will be available for you to look.
Is how can you actually
create a coded aperture.
So this is my conventional aperture,
right?
Just the opening.
I know the size and all the the amount
of light that it goes through.
Can we actually create a mask?
Referred to as a code here and
the aperture plane that makes
the defocus planes different when
they actually register on the sensor.
And if they're different they
might be easier to discriminate.
So basically, that suggests us, we
want to actually add a coded aperture,
it basically, let's in less light,
but in a known pattern like this.
What's the artifact of this?
Let's look at exactly,
the example we looked at before
of our lens and defocus.
Remember, we had looked at this before.
We basically, had an object moved up.
And, of course, it created these
patterns from a single light source.
So here, of course, we have an image
of a defocused point light source.
Of course, when we replace it,
this will look different.
Right?
because now less light will come in.
Of course, that basically says,
how do we kind of build this as we
now create obstructions on the lens.
Like I'm just going to show
you one simple example here.
Basically, how I'm going to
represent these things are simple
obstructions shown here.
So basically, this line here is eh,
maybe considered to be
one of these things.
And I'm going to basically say, if I put
an obstruction like this on the lens,
basically means is now this part of
the light is not making it to my sensor.
And, of course, that translates into a
spread function that would be different.
Similarly, I would actually put
another one just to kind of see what
the effect is.
And again, that also goes in there.
And translation is that, of course,
now I have a point spread function
that also has a different look.
You know, maybe like this.
This was the output based on this.
Again, notice this is what
we're trying to do here.
The same object far away putting simple
to obstructions, we get a newer image or
a newer output.
But we can now start calibrating this.
Recall again,
we did this kind of same trick when we
were talking about light field cameras.
Again, simple example,
further, same obstructions.
I moved the object closer.
Spread function is different.
Of course, now I can start
calibrating for these types of things
as I move closer and closer you
can basically see the end of it.
Doesn't matter what it is.
If I actually move
the light source here,
the spread function will come
back to what I expected for
a regular aperture, because this,
everything is in focus.
Of course, the final one,
when the object is on the focal plane.
Of course, the image is created here.
Our spread function is there.
And while there might be a small
impact of the obstructions here for
full-focus thing,
you'll actually get a spread you know,
the image to be much smaller,
and a point spread function, but
also be like the one we'd expected in
case where there was no obstructions.